2019 may seem like it's a long way off, but
movie studios are already filling up their
slates with big-budget, high-octane adventures
that theatergoers are not going to want to
miss.
While some may say it's a bit early for people
to be setting their calendar for midnight
release dates, we say that you can never plan
too much ahead.
You might even get some sweet merch!
"Star Wars fans brave the cold, long lines,
and traffic.
The first one thousand people got an exclusive
Rogue One poster!"
So pop all your popcorn and clear space on
the wall for all your sweet new posters...here
are all the movies that will blow you away
in 2019.
The Lego Movie Sequel
The first Lego Movie was the surprise hit
of 2014, making $469 million worldwide and
spawning a host of spin-offs, including the
Lego Batman movie, which made over $300 million
worldwide in 2017.
However, the actual sequel to the original
film has run into some production delays,
pushing its release back to February 2019.
One of the reasons for the hold-up?
A script rewrite from BoJack Horseman creator
Raphael Bob-Waksberg.
Now that we can't wait to see.
How to Train Your Dragon 3
Check out the intense logline for How to Train
Your Dragon 3: "As Hiccup fulfills his dream
of creating a peaceful dragon utopia, Toothless'
discovery of an untamed, elusive mate draws
the Night Fury away.
When danger mounts at home and Hiccup's reign
as village chief is tested, both dragon and
rider must make impossible decisions to save
their kind."
Oscar-nominated writer and director Dean DeBlois
says the third movie in the franchise, set
for release in March 2019, will be the "culmination
of Hiccup's coming of age.”
So expect the movie to tie the whole franchise
together in one epic conclusion.
Captain Marvel
Marvel's first female-led superhero film,
pegged for March 2019, is shaping up to be
worth the wait.
For one thing, Captain Marvel has Oscar winner
Brie Larson as its lead, an actress who's
shown she has the ability to pull off action,
comedy, and drama.
And for another, Marvel enlisted the directing
team of Anna Boden and Ryan Fleck, who previously
helmed cult hits Half-Nelson and It's Kind
of a Funny Story.
Add in the promise from Marvel head honcho
Kevin Fiege that Captain Marvel will be "as
powerful a character as we've ever put in
a movie" and you have the recipe for yet another
winner from Marvel Studios.
Godzilla: King of Monsters
Another March release, King of Monsters is
the follow-up to the well-received 2014 Godzilla.
But that's where the similarities apparently
end.
Other than returning star Ken Watanabe, the
movie is slated to bring in a whole new cast
of human characters, with Vera Farmiga, Kyle
Chandler, and Stranger Things star Millie
Bobby Brown playing a family swept up in the
trouble the monster causes.
Sorry, Godzilla, but we're betting on Eleven...
“Ah!
She broke my arm!
My arm!”
“Go.”
Shazam!
It's been a long time in the making, but the
long awaited Shazam! movie from DC is currently
slated to finally hit theaters in April 2019.
Although Warner Bros. has yet to announce
a lead, Shazam! promises to bring a new, lighter
tone to DC's otherwise pretty grim film universe.
Whether or not Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson will
appear as Black Adam remains to be seen, as
Shazam's archenemy has already had his own
solo film greenlit.
Either way, it'll be nice to see a DC film
where at least one scene takes place during
daylight hours.
"Shazam!"
Fast & Furious 9
Vin Diesel teased the release date for the
ninth and tenth films in the Fast and the
Furious franchise on his Instagram before
The Fate of the Furious even had its official
name.
And with the eighth movie tearing up the box
office in 2017, the ninth is sure to be huge.
Considering the Fate of the Furious purposely
left some loose ends dangling, it seems as
though the stage is already being set to make
Fast & Furious 9 the fastest and most furious
film yet.
If that's even possible.
Avengers 4
In May 2019, the fourth Avengers film will
mark the end of Marvel's Phase 3, which means
it's probably time to break out your tissues.
With the first wave of Marvel film franchises
coming to an end — and with many of the
big-name actors' contracts expiring as well
— Avengers 4 will probably result in quite
a few character deaths or retirements.
We'll learn a lot more about what to expect
in Avengers 4 when Avengers: Infinity War
hits theaters in 2018.
But the movie is sure to be a can't-miss adventure.
Star Wars: Episode IX
Jurassic World's Colin Trevorrow will take
on directing duties for the as-yet-untitled
final film in the third Star Wars trilogy,
currently slated for a may 2019 release.
And if the past films have been any indication,
this one is going to be epic. 2017's The Last
Jedi should tell us a lot about the plot of
Star Wars: Episode IX, but we do know that
it'll provide a resolution to the trilogy,
according to Lucasfilm president Kathleen
Kennedy.
And, if just the plot of the movie isn't enough
to get you out to the theaters, the studio
is looking to set up a future of standalone
movies and spinoffs — meaning Episode IX
will probably be yet another launching pad
for years of the Star Wars franchise's future.
May it never end.
Toy Story 4
If you somehow didn't empty your tear ducts
forever during Toy Story 3, Toy Story 4 will
arrive in June 2019.
According to Pixar chief creative officer
and Toy Story director John Lasseter, the
treatment for the film, was "unbelievable,"
focusing on the love story between Woody and
Bo Peep and showing Woody and Buzz teaming
up to find a missing Bo.
The movie also has big names behind it, with
Lasseter set to co-direct alongside Inside
Out writer Josh Cooley, and a script by Celeste
& Jesse Forever duo Rashida Jones and Will
McCormack.
“I’m Rashida Jones.”
“I’m Will McCormack.
And we are currently at Pixar writing Toy
Story 4.”
The Pixar machine hasn't failed us yet, and
we're excited to see their animated rom-com
on screen.
Transformers 7
Don't look now, but there's yet another Transformers
movie coming out!
Actually, there's two, as Transformers 8 has
already been announced too, with several more
spinoffs and sequels in development.
Just what will happen in June 2019's Transformers
7 is a closely guarded secret.
But we're going to give you an exclusive right
now: it will involve CGI robots punching each
other until your eyes and ears bleed motor
oil.
The only thing that could be better?
If someone figured out how to combine the
franchise with Fast & Furious so all those
autobots were being driven by Vin Diesel and
Ludacris.
Hey, we can dream, can't we?
The Secret Life of Pets 2
The original Secret Life of Pets flooded movie
theaters with adorableness in the summer of
2016.
And although the sequel has been pushed back
to July 2019 from its originally planned 2018
release date, there are still a lot of good
things going for it.
Set to follow the continuing adventures of
New York City's craziest pets, the sequel
will bring back the writing and directing
team from the original.
That means it should also be able to bring
back the magic that made the first film so
great.
“The revolution has begun!
Liberated forever!
Domesticated never!
Yeah!”
Spider-Man: Homecoming 2
Tom Holland's Spider-Man is set to continue
his adventures in a second standalone film
in July 2019.
It should follow another year of Peter Parker's
high school experience, similar to the annual
installments of Harry Potter.
While we've already seen plenty of Spider-Man
films, Holland's version promises to be different
in a number of ways.
For one thing, if what Holland says is true
about the sequel staying in high school, it
will be the only Spider-Man film iteration
to remain there for more than one movie.
That way, it can mine new story ideas that
other films have breezed past.
There are lots of possibilities for Holland's
Peter Parker, and it should be interesting
to see what webs the filmmakers spin.
The Lion King
Disney's remake machine is already going strong,
and Jon Favreau's live-action version of The
Lion King, set to ascend to the throne in
July 2019, is expected to be huge.
The movie will bring back James Earl Jones
to reprise his role as Mufasa from the original,
with Donald Glover providing the voice of
Simba.
And those stars already have some equally
impressive backup in the form of Seth Rogen
and Billy Eichner, who will voice Timon and
Pumba.
Given how well Favreau's live action Jungle
Book adaptation turned out, this is one you
won't want to miss.
Frozen 2
Bundle up, because Frozen 2 is coming your
way in November 2019.
Not much is known right now about the sequel
to the 2013 mega-hit.
But we're ready to guarantee it will feature
at least a couple catchy songs that are sure
to become karaoke mainstays for the rest of
eternity.
The sequel will further explore the relationship
between Idina Menzel's Elsa and Kristen Bell's
Anna, two of Disney's most engaging and feminist
heroines to date.
So while we don't know anything specific about
the plot yet, we can guarantee that Frozen
2 is sure to warm your cold heart.
Oh, and also:
"Let it go!
Let it go!
I am one with the wind and sky!
Let it go!”
Just when you finally got that out of your
head!
Sorry.
Masters of the Universe
Despite losing McG as its director, the December
2019 Masters of the Universe live action film
is still shaping up to be a powerhouse thanks
to the writing of David S. Goyer, the guy
behind Batman Begins, The Dark Knight, Blade,
and more.
There are also a lot of A-list actors reportedly
vying to play roles in the film.
With more stars scrambling to sign on to superhero
movies in recent years, it looks like Masters
of the Universe should have no problem assembling
an impressive cast of characters.
Shrek 5
Shrek 5 won't hit theaters until nearly nine
years after Shrek Forever After, but Dreamworks
is assuring viewers it will be totally worth
the wait.
The fifth film is apparently set to launch
a reinvented Shrek franchise, with a whole
potential Shrek universe on the way as well.
Screenwriter Michael McCullers said, "there's
been four movies and a lot of material, so
the characters are pretty beloved and they're
great characters, but you also have to think
of a pretty new take at that point."
While it's unclear exactly what that reinvention
will entail, it will be pretty interesting
to see which fairy tale myths the franchise
decides to mine next.
The Batman
Right now, the big story around The Batman
comes from the movie's numerous delays.
But if you look past all the negative talk,
the film is actually shaping up to be pretty
good.
Ben Affleck may not have dissolved into the
role of Bruce Wayne as well as Christian Bale
did, but he's been improving with every appearance.
With a turn in Justice League coming up, he'll
hopefully have more time to settle into the
character and to develop his own caped crusader.
Cloverfield's Matt Reeves is also set to direct,
and the script also reportedly recently underwent
a rewrite from an Oscar winner, with Argo
and Justice League writer Chris Terrio turning
in a draft that everyone is "very happy" with.
Hopefully they'll find a way to squeeze some
of this in:
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!